what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and let's get
started but first guys guys do not
forget
we need 2 000 likes on this video to
really push it out so make sure you hit
that like button and also if you want to
be the ultimate alpha male if you want
women to come up to you left and right
and just tell you how awesome awesome
you are really get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today guys these
shirts are amazing One of a Kind the
best in the business
um I can't wait or my samples are coming
in this week so I'm going to show you
guys that live on the show when they get
in but they're awesome it's a black
shirt with white letters that just says
women shouldn't vote it gets right to
the point so it's at the audacity
Network dot store the link to that is in
the description and in the comments
section okay so we have a couple topics
that we're gonna go over today the first
is um you know as I've said guys we have
a generation of modern wives that do not
listen to their husbands um I really
classify these women really between the
40 and 60 year olds but you know my
generation doesn't really make it down
the aisle if we do we divorce but the
ones that are in marriages tend to still
have the modern wife mentality but with
less traditional skills so the 40 to 60
year old women could kind of cook
whatever like we can't do we just
deliver it all the time
Uber Eats baby you know so anyways this
um mother this wife and mother
um had a video go viral talking about a
situation with her husband did a husband
cross the line when he left his wife at
the airport the husband explained they
had about 15 minutes until boarding
started and his wife insisted on going
to Starbucks which was on a different
terminal he told her she didn't have
time but she didn't listen he waited as
long as possible but when the gate agent
was about to close the door he decided
to get on the plane and the wife did not
make the connection yeah throw the whole
wife away first of all he was going to
visit his daughter so when the wife
decided to go to another terminal with
15 minutes to board the plane she made
him make a choice between her and his
daughter so there was a trip planned
before she overslept so they already
missed the flight so this is the second
time that they're going to try to see
his daughter so when she decided that
she was going to delay or just take her
sweet time like the plane was supposed
to wait for her then he did the right
thing and he got his butt on that plane
to go see his daughter these women
giving their opinions on talk shows I
don't usually agree with but today I
actually wholeheartedly agree look it
what what is true femininity and I
thought about how interesting it was
um we have all these like femininity
coaches coming out right we have all
these women that have these just like
femininity courses about you know
fashion makeup hair and just focusing on
yourself but true femininity is
listening to the men in your life and
focusing on the men around you uh think
about it like did our great grandmothers
did they really care about the fashion
the makeup the botox like all that no
the greatest Memories We have with women
are women that were absolutely selfless
and unfortunately the women of today we
don't really have gold standard women
anymore they don't like true femininity
is listening to the men in your life
obeying the men in your life and
um
serving your husband that that's like
the core right it's it's a helpmate that
that is the core of femininity and it's
so funny because all of these femininity
courses they get it wrong like they
absolutely get it wrong they say make
these men jump through hoops make these
men do all this stuff for you when
really you're supposed true femininity
is serving
the guys the men I mean I'm not saying
do it to every guy but think about it
like think about the women in your life
that make you feel warm that make you
feel appreciated they're selfless and
when I think of these women they're not
typically women that really thought
about themselves that much they didn't
really care about fashion they didn't
really care about makeup hair and I'm
not saying like all of these things help
if your husband likes it that's the
whole point like I know feminine women
that
um like I know one and I've talked about
this couple before but she works in
marketing she doesn't even do any of the
quote-unquote Trad stuff but she does
what her husband says he says look it I
want you to work in my business and do
the marketing now don't ladies let's not
sell these dreams most of you are not
gonna date men that own businesses
that's like a small percentage of the
population so don't that that's an
exception it's not the rule but my point
my whole point is these courses and all
these women they get it wrong and the
true um the true nature of a wife is
supposed to be a helpmate so the comment
section weighed in on this and they
agree get rid of her so one woman in the
comments section Annie said it sounds
like the wife intended for him to not
see his daughter as this was the second
flight she messed with yeah and a lot of
got time and a lot of times women are
very conniving you know they just play
these stupid games so epic why is this a
question about the husband crossing the
line when there were at least six lines
crossed by the wife a hundred and eighty
two thousand likes on this guys The Tide
is turning people are starting to wake
up can Jen it sounds like she's trying
to sabotage the whole visit to me throw
the whole wife away and try again guys
we the comment section is getting more
and more red pill every day this is why
this content is so important because
really I mean 10 15 years ago this
comment section might have been the
entire opposite way I mean 10 15 years
ago the level of pandering on TV was
just absolutely ridiculous it's so crazy
to see these Steve Harvey types like and
what they would say on television
Alfonso why is everyone supporting him
after a marriage the wife should come
first he's wrong
and here is the samp it always starts
with these stamps right
um guys there's a natural order in the
world that goes God men women children
well what happens when women believe
that we're equal to men families fall
apart and um men that co-sign this are
evil and we need to start looking at
them as evil because they're simping and
pandering dust because they want female
attention and sex and you know honestly
as women we gotta we gotta be tired of
this because they go out and let us
look like idiots because they won't tell
us the truth and I'm really tired of
these guys pandering to us when the
woman was in the wrong and that women
will never learn her lesson if everybody
tells her she's awesome and amazing all
the time
the the failure rate for marriage is
about 50 give or take and now let's take
the remaining 50 if the reputation of
marriage is bad that means over half
are unsuccessful meaning they're sexless
meaning the woman belittles the man
meaning it's really just like a happy
wife happy life type relationship or the
man's doing whatever he can to make the
woman happy
um so the men kind of look at this and
this is a 75 failure rate I would say I
would argue it's probably higher this is
the I mean because we're not going to
call it a success if it yeah I mean you
guys know the type of marriages where
the guy is just absolutely miserable for
a lifetime well let's we could agree
that's a failure right
okay so there's no other contract you
would sign with a 75 failure rate
uh just like they like take the emotion
take the Disney out of it and you know
what I realized guys I had this
realization we are in a post-marriage
world most women and men will not have
Happy Endings they will not have
families if we keep going the way we're
gone it's I I don't see women getting
off of only fans I don't I maybe see a
group that has a bit of a return to
traditionalism but I really think until
we start to recognize like female nature
for what it is
um there's never going to be any
progress because you're gonna keep
seeing Christian women divorcing their
husbands like we saw in the Crowder
situation you're gonna keep seeing
religious women pat Pastor women become
only like women you know not every woman
acts on her nature not every woman will
but women we just have a way that we are
and the truth of the matter is when we
get leverage in relationships we're just
not the best people